wir reden über die eiskönigin 2 ist der
zweite teil der eiskönigin also der
zweite teil des bedeutendsten musicals
über frostbeulen und abgefahrene 10 das
jemals gedreht wurde
die vergangenheit ist anders als du
denkst du musst die wahrheit
herausfinden
[Musik]
gegen ihn nach norden
durchquert den verzauberten wald
hinein ins unbekannte verantwortlich für
dieses meisterwerk des modernen kinos
zeichnen
jennifer lee drehbuch regie chris beck
auch beteiligt christen enders und lopez
und ihr mann auch irgendein lopez die
songs geschrieben haben die man gar
nicht fassen kann das erste mal war let
it go jan welthit
[Musik]
es ist ein relativ kleiner welthit
verglichen mit dem was wahrscheinlich
aus into the unknown werden wird was die
elsa diesmal schmettert
[Musik]
es geht in diesem film um zwei
schwestern zwei königs töchter die eine
ist hochbegabt das heißt sie ist schnee
beschwören oder eis weise und ihre
schwester ist normal aber eben nicht
normal denn sie muss dafür sorgen dass
die superheldin ihre schwester aufs
menschliche maß kommen mit ihren ganzen
leidenschaft und mit ihren superkräften
und dafür muss die übermenschlich viel
liebe aufbringen für sie die beiden sind
unschlagbar unglaublich gut tolle
rollenmodelle und machen wahnsinnig
kasse für disney
ich begleite dich an nein entschuldige
aber ich habe das höchste gebirge
überquert eingefroren ist hertz überlebt
und ich von meinem exfreund gerettet
also du weißt schon ich kann mich jetzt
kann man natürlich sagen das ist alles
kommerzieller dreck im gegensatz zu
filmen die noch von hand gemacht werden
mit holz kameras wie denen von scorsese
oder woody allen
aber tatsache ist natürlich das den film
ganz schön stabil sein muss und zwei
filme noch stabiler wenn man so ein
haufen waren drauf stellt als zum
beispiel kinder bücher die man dann
lesen muss bei elsa lampen und ähnliches
zeug und der witz ist kino war schon
immer so dass es nicht darum ging dass
irgendwelche leute in verschneiten berg
hätten große romane schreiben die dann
rembrandt mit einer von men regel ihnen
kamera filmt sondern das war immer schon
eine kunst wurde bei popcorn essen
kannst eine kunst wurde beim knutschen
kannst eine kunst für die kinder
schreien vor entzücken oder weil sie
entsetzt sind und wenn die kunst so
robust ist und so gut gemacht ist und so
tief in die töpfe greift von allem was
kunst kann dann funktioniert das auch
wie bei diesen beiden filmen
sag mal du bist doch eine weise alte
frau macht sich der gedanke nicht mehr
wirst dass nichts auf dieser welt von
dauer ist
nein recht nicht eine andere nörgelt
kritik von viel zu informierten leuten
die man in letzter zeit am kino häufig
hören muss ist die machen ja nur noch
fortsetzungen
das sind ja nur noch franchise und so
weiter wobei übrigens das kino von der
ersten frau und der franchise ist
nämlich den genres seit ewigkeiten lebt
also ein krimi ist sozusagen auch nur
das aus was eine franchise halt auf
crack ist das ist einfach die
verschärfung also zu sagen ihr seid so
böse serienproduktion ist ein bisschen
seltsam im kino aber in der tat musst du
wenn du solche franchise es machst dir
ein bisschen überlegen warum machst du
fortsetzung wenn zum beispiel wie bei
frozen das ende so wahnsinnig rundum
gelungen und alles zusammenführen
geleistet ist dass du denkst das kann
das jetzt eigentlich billiger machen das
kann es nur tot reiten sowie man bei den
minions dann irgendwie beim 36 film oder
so gesagt hat jetzt will ich sie nicht
mehr sehen
das tolle ist aber dass das ende von
frozen ja sagt das herkömmliche märchen
ende wollen wir nicht mehr das
funktioniert nicht das ist einerseits
irgendwie kannst du das politisch
auffassen mit der prinz erlös die frauen
nicht mehr sie kann es selber du kannst
aber auch sagen es ist interessant weil
es überraschend ist weil die geschichte
anders erzählt ist und das geile ist
diese idee dieses enge klassische
märchen ende zu erweitern und zu sagen
das ist viel mehr möglich mit
prinzessinnen das verallgemeinert der
zweite teil in dem es generell um
verwandlung geht der schneemann olaf
sagt an einer stelle wo sie in den
zauberwald gehen ich habe gehört das
soll hier transformatorische sein da
gibt es transformation ich weiß nicht
was das bedeutet und am ende sagte ich
weiß immer noch nicht was transformation
bedeutet aber wir haben uns alle total
verändert ach ich lebe meinen traum
einer ich wünschte das würde nie
aufhören
doch die veränderung verspottet uns mit
ihrer schönheit
verzeih mir im alter werde ich noch ganz
poetisch natürlich ist disney ein
seelenloser horror konzern der so schöne
sachen macht wie kinos erpressen was sie
für pakete zeigen müssen damit sie die
filme zeigen können die sie zeigen
wollen weil da alle reingehen und die
haben jetzt durch streaming also disney
plus sozusagen diese einheit die sie
schmieden wollen aus vertrieb produktion
marketing noch enger zusammengeschweißt
werden monopolisten aber nur mit hypnose
dass du nicht monopolist deine leute
müssen das können und die leute von
frozen und rosenzweig können wahnsinnig
viel
wie kommt ihr damit klar dass die
komplexität unseres denkens mit
zunehmendem alter immer höher wird auch
nennen die nicht ablenken du weißt nicht
wo ich gerade rhein gelangt später was
sie zum beispiel können ist in der zeit
in der gefühle die man so hart
zusammenschnurren auf images und
sozusagen schnell verheizt werden und
niemand mehr ein langes musikalbum sich
anhört an den extreme was auch völlig
okay ist diese gefühle in diesem film
breit ausgewalzt werden und zwar unter
rückgriff auf tatsächlich alle techniken
die zum beispiel musikdramaturgie hat du
hast eine stelle wo diana die ohnehin
fantastisch toll ist und fast noch
fantastisch toller als ihre schwester
elsa die allerdings wiederum fantastisch
dollar ist als sie es ist ganz schwierig
in einer höhle kauert und es ist alles
ganz hoffnungslos und fürchterlich und
sie singt eine arie darüber wie
fürchterlich und hoffnungslos das ist
und es ist ein ganz klassisches
rezitativ also das was du in der oper
hast wo du nicht irgendwie offen oder
franken sollst oder auf die melodie
sondern wo die handlung weiter gebracht
wird durch sprache und wie man sozusagen
flüster wein und dabei trotzdem
irgendwie schmettern kann das siehst du
woanders nicht außer eben in der oper
und wer will schon in die oper antwort
ich will in die oper aber erst wenn ich
im kino war
hast du dich noch ordentlich machen
ich bin immer für dich da
bis alle überraschend für an dem ding
ist das in einer zeit in der sozusagen
die maschinen und die rechner generell
und umzingeln
eine alte kunst immer menschen können
von maschinen nachgemacht und verstärkt
wird nämlich die schauspielerei
das ist kein wunder dass das bei disney
passiert weil disney haben schon in den
30er jahren die idee gehabt für diesen
schneewittchen film der erste animierte
wahnsinn den sie gemacht haben
das so zu definieren animierter sektors
also die leute die die zeichnungen die
die kunst machen die die folien machen
müssen sich als schauspieler verstehen
müssen also inszenieren darstellen
müssen aber auch expressiv sein müssen
sozusagen dabei methoden beherzigen die
tief in ihr herz rein schneiden und das
findet man in den pausen film vor allen
dingen eine nebenfigur gehen hauptfigur
ist nämlich eben in dieser schwester
anna das ist kristen bell im original
nach der das stark modelliert wurde und
ich liebe kristen bell unter anderem
weil sie für verschiedene fernsehserien
wie sie gespielt hat veronica mars zum
beispiel aber in letzter zeit vor allen
dingen good place eine neue art von
körper komik erfunden hat wo ich sagen
würde das ist sozusagen geschickte
unbeholfenheit sowie es intelligent
eingesetzte dummheit gibt vor allen
dingen der politik und in der
betriebswirtschaft gibt es eben die
fähigkeit offenbar offene wahnsinnig
professionelle zu stolpern umzufallen zu
entgleisen usw
und das macht diese an einer figur die
ganze zeit was einerseits mit gefühl
weckt und andererseits just do und
jubelt du jedes mal wenn sie sozusagen
wieder aufs eis zurück klettert von dem
sie gerade runter gefallen ist und an
niemand anderem aus einem kasten welt
hätten sie das lernen können und ihr zur
seite oder sie steht zur seite oder ihr
zur seite steht diese schwester diese
elemente die das im original spielt und
die wiederum hat mit ihrem arme
ausbreiten und ähnlichem zeug sozusagen
eine gestik zurück ins kino gebracht die
wir nicht mehr gesehen haben in der
größte seit der freddy mercury nicht
mehr auf den bühnen steht und das macht
du bist der nächste urlaub ist viel
leichter jetzt wo ich lesen kann tempo
runde mädchen gegen jungs alles klar ich
bin bereit los
heiße waffeln schloss kam aus wer sollte
den film angucken den film sollten alle
leute angucken die humor haben die genug
humor haben zu wissen dass die kritik
einer fürchterlichen firma wie disney
das natürlich ist mit einer ellenbogen
marktmacht die tatsächlich die vielfalt
dessen was gezeigt wird reduzieren kann
nicht zusammenfallen muss damit dass man
sich nicht an guckt ob die leute was
können denn de facto ist es immer so die
kunst hatte schon immer als grausige
entstehungsbedingungen wenn der fürstabt
von sowieso mir sagt ich soll die decke
anmalen dann ist das auch nicht freiheit
dann ist das zwar nicht markt und
konzern aber dann ist das halt
christlicher herrschaft verherrlichung
schools und der witz ist ich glaube man
darf so viel zutrauen zu den künsten
haben zu all diesen vielen leuten die
daran beteiligt sind das das zeug immer
noch ein bisschen cleverer ist als eine
platte absicht wie wir machen damit ein
haufen geld kurze frage wird dieses wir
begeben uns in lebensgefahr bringen
jetzt zur gewohnheit
[Applaus]